hello everyone
my name is bozeman eugene and i'll be
presenting the work on card guessing
with limited memory
that shows the power of adaptive
adversaries in streams
this is a joint work with money all from
weitzman institute
card guessing is a game played by two
players a dealer and a guesser
the dealer begins the game with a deck
that consists of n distinct cards
in each turn the dealer draws a card
from the deck and place it face down on
the table
the guesser tries to guess which card
was drawn
the card is then revealed
and discarded so it can no longer be
drawn by the dealer
the guesser gets a point for every
correctly guest card
and the question we're interested in is
how many cards were guessed correctly
and since the game is random by nature
we are interested in the expected number
of correct guesses
a guesser with perfect memory
can keep track of all cards that were
drawn so far and all cards that still
reside in the deck
and simply guess a card that still
resides in the deck
on the first turn that guesser would be
correct with probability 1 over n on the
second with probability one over n minus
one
when i cards are left with probability
one over i
and when there is a single card left
that guesser would be correct with
probability one since she knows exactly
which card it is
by linearity of expectation this results
in the harmonic sum which is roughly lun
n
on the other hand a memoryless guesser
cannot do anything better than guess
with probability 1 over n
again by linearity of expectation that
results in a single correct guess
throughout the game
however a memoryless guesser can get a
single correct guess for certain by
simply repeating the same guess over and
over again
since each card must be drawn at some
point
that would mean the guesser can get this
single correct guess
for certain with probability one
these two examples are taken from a
textbook on algorithms by kleinberg and
talbos
what we're interested in is
what can be done with m bits of memory
when m
is less than n
and our answer is that it depends much
on the dealer
we consider three kinds of dealers
the first dealer we consider is a random
shuffle dealer
that dealer shuffles the deck properly
at the beginning of the game and then
draws cards one by one
this is equivalent to drawing a random
card in a return from the set of
remaining cards
or to sample a permutation pie
and at turn i
draw the card pi i
the second dealer we consider is a
static dealer
that dealer can be somewhat familiar
with the guesswork strategy
so that dealer pre-arranges the deck in
some specific order in order to in order
to fail the guesser
this can be thought of as a mild
adversarial ability
the third dealer we consider is an
adaptive dealer
that dealer draws cards thoughtfully in
an adversarial manner
in response to
how the guesser played so far
as for the guesser she has n bits of
memory that she uses for a card guessing
function
and she updates these end bits using a
state transition function
she may use randomness for both
functions and we refer to this
randomness in two ways
some random bits should be available and
last throughout the game while others
are used exactly once
we charge the guesser for long lasting
random bits but we don't care about how
many on the fly random bits are used
the card guessing function takes
the n bits of memory
the long lasting randomness and possibly
on the fly random bits and produces a
guess
as for the state transition function
along the memory and random bits the
function also gets the current card in
order to produce the next memory state
in this talk i will cover four of our
main results from our paper
there is a low memory guesser that
scores very well against a random
shuffle dealer
one that draws cards randomly
there is also a low memory guesser
against any static dealer that fixed the
deck in advance
these two guessers are optimal in the
sense that no guesser can perform
similarly with less memory
and we also show an adaptive dealer
against which no guesser can do anything
better than using her memory to keep
cards in mind
in our first two possibility results we
will count explicitly all random bits
used by our guessers
while for our
last two impossibility results
they hold even if the guesser is allowed
to have unlimited amount of randomness
here are some simple techniques
that a guester may use with only end
bits of memory
the guesser can pretend
that there are only m cards in the deck
and keep track of these m cards using
hair and bits of memory and play as if
she has perfect memory of these m cards
as this card must appear at some point
then she gets the first one with
probability one over m the second with
one over n minus one and she gets about
one n correct guesses in expectation
we call this technique subset guessing
another technique is called remembering
the last cards
with only log n bits the guesser can
guess the last card with probability one
the guesser initialized the memory her
initialize her memory with the sum of
all cards module n and subtract the
value of each drawn card from the sum
when a single card left the guesser
knows exactly which card it is as it is
written clearly in her memory
this technique generalizes well to k
cards using k log n bits giving the
guesser a fair chance to guess the last
m over log n cards resulting in
lan m over log and correct guesses in
expectation
the two methods are actually compatible
when playing against a random shuffle
dealer the guesser can allocate half her
memory for subset guessing and half for
remembering the last cards and if the
guesser has
square root of n bits of memory then the
last card from the subset is expected to
appear before we remember the last cards
and with m equals square root of n
this is near optimal
but we can do
better
this brings us to our first result
there is a deterministic guessing method
using only m bits of memory that
achieves half square root of m correct
guesses in expectation when playing
against a random shuffle dealer
in other words with
log square and bits of memory
one get
very close to the
optimum possible with perfect memory
and
we do it using the simple idea of
remembering the last card
the idea is to follow the cards that
appeared in multiple subsets of n
for each subset we maintain two
accumulators
one is the sum of the values of the card
scene so far and 2 is the number of
cards from the subset we have seen so
far
since there are n cards each of them
requires only log n
bits of memory and in general for a set
of size s we need to log s
whenever
there is a subset with a single missing
card then we can detect that this is
indeed the case because we know how many
cards appeared from this set
and
we know which card it is because it is
explicitly written in the memory
therefore guessing this card is a
reasonable guess in the sense that this
card still resides in the deck and has a
positive probability to be drawn
in particular consider the subsets 1 one
until two one until four one until eight
and so forth
and
whenever there is a range from which a
single card is missing
then we guess this card
this is our algorithm
this construction has a
nice property
which we will use and is for every two
subsets one until w and one till w prime
such that w prime is bigger than w
then
if
some card is missing from one until w
then it is also the one missing from one
until w prime and there cannot be a
different one
in terms of space each subset of size w
requires log w bits for the counter and
log w bits for the sum and since there
are log n subsets we get that tracking
these ranges requires roughly log square
and bits of memory
as per the performance consider a random
ordering of the deck represented by a
random permutation
we call a subset useful if the last card
from it that appears in the permutation
is different from the last card from the
following subset
if a range is useful
then we guess the last card correctly as
our guest repeats guessing this last
card
and we attribute this correct guess to
this useful subset
so essentially the number of good
guesses is simply the number of useful
ranges
consider the event that a subset one
until w is useful
that is that the last card from 1 until
w is not the last card in the next range
1 until 2w
the probability for that event
is the probability
that in the next range 1 until 2w the
last card does not come from 1 until w
now
since the permutations are sampled
uniformly at random
each card from 1 until 2w has the same
probability to be drawn last
therefore the probability
for that event
is exactly half
by linearity of expectation
we get that the expected number of
useful subsets is exactly half log n
we can amplify this technique and
getting closer to lan and correct
guesses by having more subsets and make
them denser
if the ratio between two successive
subsets would be one plus gamma then we
would have log n of base 1 plus gamma
such
subsets and the probability of each one
being useful is gamma over 1 plus gamma
the expected number of useful subsets
and as a result the expected number of
correct guesses goes to lan n as gamma
goes to zero
a simple adversarial argument shows that
for every deterministic guesser there is
always a bad deck arrangement on which
that guesser managed to make at most a
single correct guess
as guessing the last card correctly may
be inevitable
this is also true for our guesser and
it's even very simple all one have to do
is put the card 1 at the bottom of the
deck and our guesser will continue
guessing it over and over again
resulting in a single correct guess
which would be on the last card
so it is clear that we must use
randomness against static dealers
one thing we can do is to sample random
permutation pi just randomize our
subsets so that will track the subset pi
one pi two pi one pi two by three by
four and so on
the performance would hold us before but
we would require
order and login bits of long lasting
randomness
which is something we wish to avoid
so
in the paper we showed that it's enough
to sample a pairwise independent
permutation to randomize the subsets
the amplification is a bit trickier and
requires higher wise independence
as the analysis is fundamentally
different
but information wise it is the same
guesser
so
with order log square and bits of memory
and only two log n bits of long lasting
randomness a randomized subset guesser
can score quarter land and correct
guesses against any static dealer
so we conclude that there is a
randomized guessing method using only
log square n bits of memory and log
square and bits of long lasting
randomness that obtains quarter land and
correct guesses in expectation when
playing against any static adversary
furthermore
this can get amplified to one end by
paying only a log factor of both memory
and randomness
but what happens if m is even smaller
so what actually happens if m is small
say much smaller than log square of n
well in this case we can treat the
domain as if it is of size 2 to the
square root of n and simply ignore all
other cards
now m equals log square of 2 to the
square root of m and we can run the
previous guessers on smaller domain
and get
square root of m correct guesses on
expectation
but maybe there is something better that
we can do
so
the answer is no
no guesser with n bits of memory can
score better than order of square root
of m when playing against a random
shuffle dealer
this is also true for a static dealer
but we show it for a random dealer
the idea is that a guesser is a machine
that generates information
and if this information is particularly
good
then we can utilize this information to
encode ordered sets efficiently
proof by encoding is a general method to
prove the success of a randomized
process by showing that bet events
allows us to compress random bits used
since the probability of compressing and
chopping off w bits is 2 to the minus w
we get a bound on the probability for
too many bad events to happen
some notable examples are moser and
tardash proof for the algorithmic lava
slow column
the success rate of cuckoo hashing
and oracle separation results in crypto
the main ingredient for proof by
compression is an encoding scheme in the
form of encode and decode functions
for a random object from some domain
back to our proof
we would like to show that it is
impossible to get close to one and
correct guesses which is the optimum
with little o of log square and bits of
memory
in other words we want to show that our
guessers are optimal and it is
impossible to perform similarly with
less with significantly less memory
let m be smaller than log square n and
set beta to be a fraction
we claim that any guessing algorithm
using n bits of memory can get at most
that many correct guesses on expectation
where the expectation is taken over the
random shuffle of the deck
for beta equals ln over square root of m
this is 2 square root of n
so as we said we will use the guessing
algorithm to encode an ordered set of
size t where t equals n to the 1 minus
beta and we will show that if there are
too many correct guesses then our
encoding function produce descriptions
of length of length shorter than the
entropy of a random ordered set
of size t
we will focus on bounding correct
guesses in the last t terms
let a random variable l be the number of
correct guesses in the last t turns and
let b be the bottom of the deck that is
b is an ordered set of size t
we will assume that the guesswork plays
perfectly in the first n minus t turns
and hence makes better lon and correct
guesses in the first part of the game
we will simulate the guesser and see
when the l correct guesses are made in
the last t turns and we will utilize
them to describe b efficiently
to encode a random ordered set b we
consider a guesser with fixed randomness
so we don't need to encode the random
bits
and we consider the guesser's memory
state t steps from the end of the game
we then encode b by storing the guessers
ambit of memory the allocations at which
the guess are guessed correctly
this takes log t choose l bits
and the cards that were not guessed
correctly in their respective order
so to have things visualized
in order to encode an ordered set b
we simulate a game where the first n
minus t cards are not from b
and they are arranged randomly
we take a snapshot of the guesswork's
memory state
and we continue the game with cards
ordered according to b
we write down the l turns at which the
guesser guessed correctly and we write
explicitly the cards drawn at other
terms
this is our encoding
we get the contradiction from counting
the number of ordered sets b in two
different ways
one is the number of possible ordered
subsets of n of size t
and 2 is an upper bound on the number of
descriptions made by our encoding scheme
and since the number of descriptions
must be larger than the number of
ordered sets we get an inequality that
describes the relation between the
gesture's memory and the number of
correct guesses in the last t terms
as a conclusion we showed that there is
a guesser that using m bits of memory
managed to obtain half of square root of
m correct guesses in expectation
and that any guesser with m bits of
memory can get at most order of square
root of m correct guesses in expectation
when playing against a random shuffle
dealer
we know that we can randomize this
guesser by sampling a random permutation
and these results would hold also for
as any static dealer
this leads us to the most prominent case
where the dealer may draw cards
adaptively in an adversarial manner
the dealer may choose cards based on
past guesses and we assume that the
dealer doesn't see the gaster's memory
or randomness
we further assume that the dealer is not
aware of the guesser's algorithm
observe that in this case the two basic
guessing techniques still works
both focusing on a subset of cards and
remembering the last cards meaning that
we can still get lanam correct guesses
in expectation
however these techniques are no longer
compatible as there exists an adaptive
dealer that checks which cards are a
guest and put these cards at the bottom
of the deck diminishing the benefits of
using the two methods
another thing to consider is whether the
dealer knows how much memory the guesser
has
we will show that in both cases there
exists an adaptive dealer against which
any guesser managed to make at most
roughly lon m correct guesses
the general idea of our adversary is
simply to refrain from drawing recently
guest cards that is moving these cards
to the back
and we shuffle the deck every once in a
while making all cards available for
drawing again
the dealer begins the game with a
properly shuffled deck and draw cards at
random
at some point the dealer begins to move
cards to the back and reshuffle at
predetermined turns which may be known
to the guesser
towards the end of the game the dealer
gets back to drawing cards at random
observe that our dealer doesn't know
anything about the guesser
and the only difference between the
memory aware and unaware dealers
is the way they are parameterized
we refer to the span of turns between
reshuffles during which the dealer moves
cards to the back by the term epoch
each epoch has three parameters
k l and u
k stands for the beginning of the epoch
and is the amount of turns left until
the end of the game right after the
reshuffle
ki is the beginning of the eighth epoch
l stands for the length or duration of
the epoch and u
which bounds the number of cards we
moved to the back during an epoch
u is necessary so that cards will not
become too predictable and so the dealer
will have cards left to draw
the important property of this strategy
is that during a move to the back epoch
a card may be a reasonable guess only
once
because once it is guessed it will not
be drawn by the dealer
assuming no more than you cards were
moved to the back
so the guesser has a single shot to
guess a card she knows resides in the
deck as all other attempts to guess this
card would be futile and recall that
guessing the same card over and over was
exactly how our low memory guesser
worked
so this strategy is efficient against
our previous guesser
by the choice of our parameters during
any point in the epoch the dealer has at
least k minus l minus u cards to draw
from
therefore the probability for a
reasonable guess to be correct is at
most 1 over k minus l minus u
as a result and by linearity of
expectation
the expected number of correct guesses
during an epoch is upper bounded by r
over k minus l minus u where r is the
expected number of reasonable guesses
during that epoch
so all we have to do is upper bound the
amount of reasonable guesses and we will
do it as we did previously via
compression argument
we will use an encoding scheme for
subsets of n of size k1 parameterized
with some threshold alpha
when we want to encode a subset d
we will simulate a game between a
guesser and our dealer with fixed
randomness corresponding to d being the
bottom of the dealer's deck
notice that we can always keep any k1
cards for the end
if the guesser makes less than alpha
reasonable guesses during the ith epoch
then we store d explicitly
but
if the guesser makes more than alpha
reasonable guesses then our encoding
consists of
the guesser's memory state a turn n
minus k1
right before the dealer begins moving
cards to the back
the first alpha turns in the eighth
epoch during which the guests are
guessed reasonably
we also store which of these reasonable
guesses were correct so that we can
reproduce the curse of the game during
decode
and we also store all other cards drawn
by the dealer
these are the cards for which the
guesser did not provide sufficiently
good information so we store them
explicitly
so overall so overall we get an encoding
of some size which we compared to the
number of possible elements in the
domain
and we get a relation between m the
gessor's memory and alpha
where alpha also describes how many bits
we save
and thus we bound the probability for
the guesser to make more than alpha
reasonable guesses in every epoch
and by bounding that probability we
bound the expected number of reasonable
guesses in an epoch
so now all we have to do is parameterize
our dealers and epochs
for the memory size aware dealer we
configure each epoch to be of size m log
n and we get that no guesser with m bits
of memory can make more than order of
one correct guesses
while the dealer moves cards to the back
as for our universal dealer we set each
epoch to be shorter by a factor of log n
than the previous epoch
we also set the upper bound differently
so that when the guesser has
insufficient memory we call it the low
memory era
the strategy works in favor of the
dealer but during the high memory era
the guesser's benefit is modest
as a conclusion
for every n there exists an adaptive
dealer parameterized according to m
against which any guesser with n bits of
memory makes at most one m correct
guesses in expectation
and
there exists an adaptive dealer
universal one
against which any guesser with ambits of
memory makes at most roughly 1m correct
guesses in expectation
the fact that these results holds even
if the guesser has lots of randomness
and crypto and is computationally
unbounded
while the dealer is very simple and
computationally efficient emphasizes
that it is the adaptivity that plays the
key role here
the first paper we found on card
guessing dates back to 1924 where ronald
fisher suggested and analyzed a scoring
system for card guessing to measure
one's claim of having psychic abilities
such as clairvoyance or telepathy
his paper can be found online in the
proceeding of the society for psychical
research
in 1981 the acconysson grams started the
game where there are multiple copies of
each card and the guesser receives
different kinds of feedback
and there are also more recent papers
about other variants of the game
here are some open problems
to amplify our guesser against the
static dealer we paid a log factor in
order to get closer to lan m but perhaps
there is a finer way
it is very interesting to see what
happens when there are multiple copies
of each card
our low memory techniques do not scale
with the number of copies and if there
are too many copies then a memory less
guesser can outperform our low memory
guesser
what happens if the dealer and the
guesser switch roles
and now the dealer is memory bounded
so she doesn't remember which cards are
still available and she may not draw the
same card twice
there exists a strategy for m bits
dealer against which any guesser makes n
over m correct guesses in expectation
but we do not know if this is optimal
it is also interesting to see if our
techniques are useful for real world
gambling
it seems appropriate to finish with
george santayana's words
those who cannot remember the past are
condemned to repeat it
and we add that this holds
even if you use randomness and
cryptography and even if you are
computationally unbounded
thank you